and I heard do you actually hurt
yourself in the first number I did and
then have to bandage yourself up and
keep going
listen I just finished like a 56 city
tour like you know Alan staged for two
hours non-stop and then the very first
move with a special I came out it did
like a little James Brown split and I
ripped my hamstring keep going like
Beyonce taped it up with duct tape and
they just kept going on and and honestly
you know luckily you can't really tell
but I definitely the tears willing to my
eyes when I'm smile I'm so happy about
Christmas released a song write a new
song like an anthem for 2020 right yeah
you know what 2020 is coming up it's
it's a beginning the new decade and
there's a song called say it now that I
you know it's out there and it's a it's
about sort of acting in the moment you
know saying it right now there's no time
like the present you know we're often
like you know someday I'll do this
someday I'll do that but it's a great
expression that says you know the path
is someday leads to a town called
nowhere right we keep putting it off so
it's sort of like let's do it right now
so yeah I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this